all right welcome back I am joined by a
group of young men who are making a big
impact TV industry of course where I was
looking for our next big local star and
and we've got one here Jeremiah amen
Jeremiah wave to everybody yes we know
Jeremiah because we featured him here on
the program
um interviewing talented athletes
professionals around the valley but the
reason we're talking with Demetrius Tate
today the founder of sports for free LV
is you've got an event coming up and the
idea is to help out these young kids not
only in athletics but in presence and
performance so let's let's first of all
talk a little bit about your non-profit
Demetrius hello so sports for free is a
non-profit organization I specialize in
providing opportunity through Youth
Sports by paying for kids registration
fees which we also created sports for
free youth media we're the first of our
kind we have kids of PR editing camera
boys uh reporters and commentators
you've got it all yes ma'am so what we
wanted to do was highlight youth media
with youth sports kids and they Youth
Sports
um
ah well and the sports though taking its
back a step is so important we know how
important Sports is for kids and we're
watching uh Jeremiah here right now but
the cost can be incredible to families
and so your organization is trying to
help these young kids get into these yes
Athletics which are great for for team
uh participation and for development and
growth yes so that's one aspect yes
ma'am and so then you've got this event
coming up uh which I'm excited to take
part of it's coming up on Saturday June
3rd and and that's where you're going to
bring in the whole um interviewing
skills like Jeremiah was just showing
off and and Demetrius have you done this
as well yeah I've been starting
interviews because one day my sister she
was a little nervous to do some
interviews so I just went for it he just
stopped right up like it was no big deal
you're going to be in my chair here in a
minute and so the goal here is to create
that performance and that confidence yes
ma'am and get more kids involved in
youth media so how can Folks at home
we're sitting there watching this kids
are out of school how can they get
involved in this event coming up on the
third
um please just pull up it's at the Boys
and Girls Club 2850 South Lindell from
10 a.m to 1pm okay and yes open to the
public we are asking for donations it is
a free event but we're looking to raise
money to get more equipment for our
company and you've got a lot of sports
commentators and and TV personalities
from the valley who are going to be
there Jeremiah are you going to be able
to lend them some insight as well
because you have met some big time
celebrities
yeah I'll probably give them some advice
probably to not be nervous and just go
for it because it's not really supposed
to be pressure and explore a fun thing
it's supposed to be fun to do well how
do you not get nervous uh I guess since
I've been thinking about it since I was
four when it just happens I'm like I
didn't come true let's just knock it out
the park and I think he does that right
if you follow him on Instagram uh
Jeremiah it's Jeremiah 5-0 and Jeremiah
one and five one in five okay so there
you go you got to follow him on
Instagram and see everything that he's
done Demetrius YouTube stepping right up
no nerves at all uh sometimes it depends
because I did a couple big celebrities
too like I did big boy that's on the
radio very Payton wow okay I did a lot
of um
I went to a celebrity basketball game
and I met a lot of basketball players
and football players and stuff you guys
are stars and I'm so excited that you're
going to be talking to the kids here in
the community Demetrius Tate thank you
so much if you have any questions we're
going to put all this information on our
website I hope your kiddos and you will
check out this big event guys thanks for
coming in today
regardless because I don't want to be
the only one getting shot oh well there
you go you got to give shine to both and
shout out to sports for free all right
may I ask you two questions really quick
because we got to go to break do one
question
um do you prefer peanut butter and jelly
or ham and cheese oh can I go with
almond butter and jelly yeah okay
there's the answer